welcome back everybody humana the
sponsors of this next segment partnered
up with kenno health to provide extra
care for the community i spoke to both
to learn more
rachel of humana dr aguilar of kennel
welcome to the show
so glad to be here thank you rocky yes
hi rocky i'm thrilled to be here thanks
so much for the opportunity absolutely
absolutely so dr aguilar this question
is for you um you guys are bringing in a
new primary care center to las vegas
tell us about that
well rocky i'm so excited to be talking
to you about it today like you said
regular visits to your primary care
office is incredibly important for
maintaining your health and preventing
problems especially as we age
according to a recent stanford study
actually access to your primary care
provider was associated with a longer
lifespan for populations so really
excited to be opening up a brand new
primary care center right here in las
vegas specifically focus on serving the
medicare population and canada is really
proud to be helping increase access to
our community absolutely and thank you
guys for joining forces here and
bringing such help to our community
rachel is there anything else you want
to add about the new primary care center
uh yes at humana our work with kano
health and other providers in our
network is an important part of our
commitment to improving population help
in the communities we serve and offering
compassionate integrated care to our
medicare advantage members by working
with providers who share our focus and
who are opening centers like the one
here in las vegas
we hope to increase the quality of and
access to care for our medicare
advantage members
and who's invited to this primary care
center so we open up the invitation for
all the community members just to come
take a look at the beautiful facility
the great uh clinicians that we have
to have access to a friendly comfortable
environment so people from the community
but specifically those elderly in the
medicare population to access the great
services we provide for them absolutely
and rachel how can people get more
information about the primary care
center and about what you guys are doing
for us
well if you're interested in learning
more about humana plans we encourage you
to call a licensed sales associate at
1-800-345
monday through friday 8am to 8pm you can
also visit
healthvetcares.com to learn more
okay well thank you so much rachel dr
aguilar we appreciate you in everything
you're doing for our community
especially for our elderly
so thank you very much
thank you humana for sponsoring that
segment for more information you can
call 1-800-345-8017
monday through friday 8 am to 8 pm or
just visit
healthvaccares.com las vegas now will